we have apologies from
robbie and sarah
where all the rest of us are here
i'll move they'll be accepted duncan i'm
second there to put that all those in
favor please
carry
any conflicts of interest
appear to be none
any corrections
two minutes
monique
[Applause]
tell kayla to where that is we'll get
that corrected
i'm prepared to remove these options of
the minutes with that correction
i'm glad i duncan seconded by jason i'll
put that all those in favor please say i
actually carried
any matters arising
appear to be none
right bernard if you like to come
forward and
sit
sit up there yes we give you
uh up to 10 minutes and you may get some
questions vernon's going to be kingsbury
from cuss is going to be talking about
the
custom
it's good to have you here just
just before you speak just like to
acknowledge
all the work you do in your community
over a very long time thank you and it's
good to see your interest hasn't waned
at all
so if you'd like us to press a talk bit
on your
50 years this year so i took over from
my father
and but we've got a great facility down
there and it's 27 acres
and
we're
it's mainly used it's used for camping
it's always been used for camping in the
days of the old class grand prix we
um
people used to camp there so
unfortunately the good thing about this
we've always got someone near camping
and we don't have the vendors and
but we've virtually improved it we've
got a question area two cricket fields
which we don't have to tip our teams at
the moment but
uh there's needed we've got
um
a um bmx trap
of sorts then
but it's mainly here is for the local
community to walk their dogs
and i'd just like the support of this
committee to
uh that if we could maybe replicate
another seat
in the west area of the domain
for people who walk the dogs in that
area it's quite a regular
and also we've had a request for some
sort of goal post
for kid
boys or girls to kick things through
and that's right kirsten
and
as well as uh
we'd like to
have a um exercise stations
around
and that would be quite a good funding
required for them
but that's basically why i've come here
just to get your support
for these new uh things down there
thank you
do you have a um
a priority order if we had some spare
cash or money in our budget
i think the seats would be a city
another city well you do have
a couple of seats in the main village
another one in the west
area
if we were able to
provide it for you we wouldn't be
telling you where to put it we want you
to put it the way you wanted to so don't
worry about that yes um
the demand tool will maintain their
money today
and it's a really popular place
for the community
yeah and
i just think we'd like to improve
improving it through the years
give me questions
donations
it's a very good idea um
i i was involved with um this seat
[Applause]
[Music]
several years ago we did a landscape
plan for the
and
it's pretty well um i think we've pretty
well got
you know
enough trees it's just
around where the pine trees were used to
be around the outside we've struggled
with to them
to come away so i think possibly we need
a bit some more replacements
and
it's it's a quite a dry area and these
suitable trees
that
stand up to the winds as well
all right any other questions
appear to be none thank you vernon for
coming along it's a very succinct and
very clear presentation we know exactly
what you're looking for
and priorities so thank you
[Applause]
all right there's no adjourning business
we now
move to
item six
point one recommended speed limit
changes our pages 18 to 114
alice and joey
[Applause]
hi everyone so the purpose of this
report is to update the board on the
results from the recent speak on a
consultation and obtain a recommendation
for council the consultation was carried
out over a three week period and overall
297 submitters provided feedback
we also sought feedback from key
stakeholders like the new zealand police
warfare tapi and various other
organizations
as you can see from the results the
majority favored lower speeds in the
cast area however matched results were
received for their own euro proposals
the recommendation in this report does
include all of the speed that was
proposed around europe and technical
reasoning has been provided in section 4
as to why this is
the majority of the roads unfavored by
the public contain high-risk inspections
which will reduction imposes speed limit
will reduce the impacts of crash while
little kid
the likes of oxford road and john's road
70 kilometers per hour zones also did
not see fable of the public however due
to development which has occurred in the
increase in vehicles and turn movements
and also melting multi-modal traffic in
these areas this speed limit is now
unsafe
a reduction speed on it along sea bridge
road was faded and therefore it is
expected to highly tell hillary
community board will vote in support of
a reduction of 80 kilometers per hour as
there is insufficiently to retain a 100
kilometer per hour speed limit on
flaxseed road within its current bounds
without either encroaching on ski roof
road or extending 100 kilometer per hour
zone into the current 80 it is
recommended that this is reduced to 18.
a reduction in speed limit was also not
favored on mars road however with the
current main operating speed less than
40 kilometers per hour a reduction to 60
will have little impact on the users of
this ride
we are recommending that the board adds
in o'rourke's road between oxford road
and jobs road to the recommendation
at a proposed speed of 80 tons per hour
while it's not consulted on the
currently operating speed along here is
63 kilometers per hour
with an annual daily traffic count of
182 vehicles per day
the safe and appropriate speed for this
road is 80 kilometers per hour
so the recommended option is to provide
a recommendation of all the proposed
speed limit reductions including the
addition of the rooks right
every day any questions
questions
morris
a remote
yes
yes sorry just to clarify it's only a
rooks road between swananoa road and
john's road which is the same portion
and it's within the triangle of 80s
which were already proposed so that was
one that we have most um but it makes no
sense at all to me but at 100 because
it's fully bounded by 80s around it yeah
it's so good yeah it's not not the
unseen
[Applause]
um
is
[Applause]
um back to your table
where you've got roads which
show obvious
disfavor
shall we say
um
like some of them are getting up into
the
sixty percent
has there been
significant
accidents or pressures or anything to
really mirror
some of those areas that are not so
favored by the problem
yes so that's all taken into account
when you calculate the same appropriate
looks at the number of accidents and
crashes that have occurred on the like
south uh friendzone riding back tomorrow
and first time it's one that we actually
do have some very regular accidents on
so long ago we had a good uh hit a
powerful
um
so it is it's a busy road it's a very
narrow road and it's highly constrained
by drains and
structures such as power poles and
through yeah it is yeah but it does make
it um
it does make it quite uh a hazard and it
does mean that the safe and appropriate
spending calculations keep it from the
application
okay um
i have to admit that when i drive on
these roads they look like 100 cameras
to me so i forget
that they've gone down the speed limits
and some of these portions already
how are you going to make it so the
environment actually looks like it needs
to be an 80k
so that drivers perform appropriately
yes i mean it's always a challenge for
us is how we remind people
and we need to do that with repeat
assignments at
regular intervals
um a big part of it is an educational
thing as well so
teaching people a little bit more about
how i see experiments and why we set
them on certain roads at lower speeds
and then
have high speeds i guess on other roads
where there are more safety pictures
so that's part of it
i think as technology
improves we're seeing more vehicles
um with the ability to be able to
cameras note what the spin limit is
as people go past so that's
a helpful tool
um but a lot of people obviously here
vehicles don't necessarily have that
technology yet so that's changing and
evolving in this area
thank you so mr chairs my final question
is on mount thomas throw not 23
it's a very wide road with
although it's got some lifestyle on it
the houses are away from the road
um why would you how can you justify
that going down to 80 and it doesn't
mean any of those accident constraints
it's not what it's not narrow
it's um quite an easy road to drive
coverage
so that section is just between oxford
road and john's room and he's trying to
get that consistent
uh area where we have a consistent speed
so when we've gone through this process
process we've really tried to think
about
um
trying to set boundaries and hearings
appropriate speed of 180.
so if they ask again how are you going
to make that look like an asynchronous
currently very easy to travel
um so
again we just we have to repair our
repeater signs we need to make sure that
we are clear to people who are driving
along that it's visible what the speed
they should be doing is
on that road
once a person's
are you going to develop these roads
they look like it should be an 80k load
at the same time to reduce it or you're
just going to
willingly reduce it and people don't
know
where they are
so
for me
to meet both hands and at the same time
you need to
downgrade the way you call it
if you wanted to
make people think that they are not
spoiling 100k zones
[Applause]
downgrading the likes of mount thomas
because
it would obviously mean narrowing it up
and trying to i guess get the
speed reduction that way
we can look at other physical
like just things like road marking to
try and narrow the lanes as opposed to
doing other work which is i think it's
more intense such as removing seal
those sort of um
yes activities
and part of the process of changing
these is that we do monitor them
we have to do speed counts six months
after um
the speed limits have changed and if we
found there was an issue there we would
look at whether we needed to do some
more to help reinforce that speed
so it sort of asked answers by
questionnaires
and it's good and cheap at the moment so
we have to actually make the roads look
like there are
80k road roads why are we changing from
180 if we actually have to actually
prove to the public that we they need to
go down to 18k by germany's operations
[Applause]
anymore
here's a main operating speed of between
70 and 74 kilometers per hour
so
we're already seeing speeds around here
we're not actually seeing and then
up and around 100
so sitting in our plane at speeding with
80 kilometers is appropriate in the
exact
situation at the moment
here's two things
sorry i mean setting the speed limit is
one thing
um
and i guess we are moving more towards
uh
trying to better inform people what
are safe for a particular road
um and we will see outliers and speed we
see that either way but i guess this is
helping to hopefully inform people
of what is if safe and appropriate speed
and trying to reduce
yester or the
severity of crashes of the way they are
to occur
this purpose of bringing these speeds
down
i thoroughly
welcome the reduction of speeds
excuse me
um down to 80 on these rural roads that
have a lot more traffic than they used
to have they're not as wise
have you got a question
could we maybe um
confirm that this is the way to go
i don't think you're in this
jason
hi sorry um
so i think in life i'm quite encouraged
encouraged by the reduction in speed i
was just quickly going through the
correspondence
is there a requirement for you to affect
it in cost or emissions with reducing
speeds
no it's not part of the calculation
environment that's just one of the nice
things
um
sorry it's um
it's not something that we currently do
as part of this setting it's been a
process but i guess it is acknowledging
that a reduction in three will result in
a reduction of capital emissions
um it's just not something that would go
on to in terms of a steep to actually
assess what that means
okay
[Music]
we've got such a busy area of tanzania
road feeding onto fernson
i was sort of surprised it stopped
through the bank although i see
obviously the public aren't very happy
with the production so i'm going to any
sidewalk anyway but is there any
consideration to maybe reduce the speed
on targeting quite such a busy road now
um
from one euro
um and then continuing with 60 so 60k
times the end of 60k on the fence like
that
piece there is there is
um i think we would probably get a lower
level of compliance like that and so
that wouldn't be a recommendation right
now
um i think that it was to be further
development in that area and all use
then we would look at that again in the
future
morris
give me a way of actually educating the
people of the new speakers with the
action
paint the speed of it on the road
because very few people look at stop
signs a good way to see
and it's actually
yep it's definitely something that we
are thinking about and using as a tool
in some places i think um we were
looking at that around the back of a
hokumo castle stream i think we've done
that
um the other thing we've done is paint
um red thresholds
on the road where there is a speed limit
change in some places
and again that can just be a visual cure
or a reminder for people that actually
do something different here that they
need to be aware of
so there are different tools and tips in
the toolbox that we can use very much
right now
[Applause]
that's always one of those things like
the more you do it and it becomes normal
the more
uh people get used to it and then
assemble some of that second hand and
ignore so
probably picking the right location to
do that
[Applause]
of the state council
because of those are probably more
likely to be rural
attractive than someone rather than
actually cars traveling on the right but
i'm thankfully very surprised how low
some of these things
so that's that they are the means this
means speed which is recorded so the
middle
um and there will be extremes at the top
end where people are traveling really
fast and there will be some extremes at
the bottom
and i think um you know if we look at
the curve
the majority will be sitting in the
middle area here
and and when you place those areas those
those speakers i noticed one for example
on one road was placed immediately
yep so in some situations we'll have
multiple counts on the road it may not
just be in one location and i think
probably giles road down highway was a
really good example of this where we had
a speed limit on i think it was on the
state section was now which was higher
speed and not through the curve but
um and we ended up
having an extra count done
to prove that actually no the speeding
operating speed through that section was
actually different from the other so
we aren't always just looking at one
source of data
we do work with our traffic contractor
in and
try to make sure we do get counts in
sensible places so
not we are now close to intersections
i'm a little bit surprised you can put
them close to a one lane bridge um
so yeah trying to put them in a location
where the results aren't being skewed
i don't mean to interrupt that you're
talking away from your microphone it's
very hard to hear you appear to store
yourself
ducking
i realize that the spade designs are a
national trend
you know i think some edge probably
implemented by a national philosophy
that does one industry council or the
whole cost of this project or
so
the funding for speed limits and speed
limit change implementation is uh partly
funded by nctas they're 50 51 percent of
that comes from ncta
and the other 49 comes from the council
budget so that's all allowed for through
our annual plan and long-term plan for
assistance
right it's time for someone going to
move it just remember whoever was moving
it to add in a rocks road between swan
and narrow road and john's road so
someone prepared to move
john moves including a rock road
seconded by monique
joan
i know there's been a lot of um
a lot of work done
on all these roads and because we've got
a lot of growth
in our region and a lot more traffic on
the roads that
we need to look at
bringing down the speed that's closer to
the prevent areas
and i think what what's happened is is
really inappropriate
monique
paul and then kirsten
while um of them
need to stay down so
i can't support the way i think the
things here on this
because of that reason and i think we
need to um
yes i'm in a similar position to call
because i think what we've got here is
urban rules things like rural roads and
i think that's quite difficult um to
justify there are certain roads here
that have become predominantly urban and
they need to go down
but some of these roads are
predominantly rural and those roads you
drive to the condition
you should actually be driving on food
side road to the conditions which means
you can drive a 100k quite safely if
it's a good day and there's not much
traffic on the road so limiting people
back to 80k and it's a totally rural
outlook is not going to ensure
compliance the only way to do that is to
change the way the road looks
now i voted accidentally in a way for
river road to go down to 50 thinking
that would be sensible but now every
time i travel on river road i forget
that it's going to be quantitative about
because the environment does not look
like a 50 kilometer in our road with a
completely dry side and we have had no
funding from dta to be able to change
that to look like an actual urban road
i do not agree that turns over it should
go down to a uk
i do not agree that milton is
all of them are predominantly rural what
someone has done none of those should go
down
past plastic's road to ada kane but i
totally support
roads such as oxford road which have
become urban and outstanding accidents
and incidents happening on those roads
we can't keep using speed limits to try
and explain
why accidents are happening that's not
the reason the reason that accidents are
happening is we have no money to approve
those intersections and ndta has
recently slashed our budget they have
splashed out that what have they loved
within half
from a very prudent practical
um course of action to look after our
roads that our own team have spent hours
and hours and
work on
and we have half the money to spend
for what we should
so the
really want to make our roads safe
they've got to stop forcing us to make
speed limits that are nonsensical in
rural areas
and they need to give us some money to
improve this section
so i have to vote against those simply
because i do not support some
of the recommendations and i do not
support
seeing how it's being done very
tractors and very slow vehicles to bring
the average down
well very briefly i'm going to support
support the recommendations
like or lump
speed restrictions these days are
becoming a norm
even a very wide long straight road
looks safe perfectly right for 100 but
unfortunately people killing people on
these roads
and the only way that i can see to
protect
innocent people
from death on our roads is to reduce
the speed limits
i don't like them coming down i have to
say but i think it makes all the sense
in the world
cursed and commented on river road
going from
down to 50 and it should have been 60
interestingly enough the board members
that were here
would remember that the board did not
want it to move below 60 and that was
their recommendation to council who
overturned it so don't blame the board
it was a little bit different but i'm
going to support it uh
other speakers
[Applause]
morris
i'll i'll be supporting reluctantly like
you jim
that
most of the time the destroyers that
follows got nothing to do with the roads
and this is really our only way to save
lives um i mean i like driving cars i
like as far as i don't exceed the
spinning of it
i live on oxford road now and when you
go to turn into my driveway people are
reluctant to pass you even if the road
is
clear
and
and i draw my attention to you know
thomas road john throw dogs around a
number of houses along there have
gateways that have to turn into
having a car coming behind you 100
kilometers an hour playing on your text
zone
you know it's not built i mean
i don't know so slow speediness but i
think this is the way forward
and and the roads are narrow and you
know mount thomas bernstein road is
narrow as well it's got a lot of traffic
on it and it's really narrow and i and i
think
um that
80 is quite reasonable and much safer
with the modern traffic that's on it now
and i do have to let you know that we're
looking seriously because even though
we've been denied a lot of
funding that we're looking at
um
um fixing or widening the bridge on
lemons
what is it they're called the culvert
okay
sorry townsend because you know that's
that's a death trap too so
um and we would love to do roundabouts
um
on that
but you know we'll be doing them as soon
as we can but in the meantime i think
it's really prudent that we bring that
spin back um on those
[Applause]
[Music]
all right next item 6.2
pages 115-139
shane
you had me
i thought shane had improved
so this report is
of albert street and high street here in
manila and is asking the board to
consider
whether to
put in place a right turn restriction at
the intersection
so this has been a request that has come
through the board
uh for the right term to be banned at
the intersection due to the delays that
each ones causes
we have carried out some
observations
on site and during the times that were
uh with review
observations were carried out
um
the delays were
around about fortified vehicles um
subsequent to this we have also noted
other occasions where they have been up
to about eight
and we did note that sometimes this was
in relation to the train going through
on high street
or also around the end of school time
where there were a lot of children or
elderly older children high school
students crossing
at albert street
so there are two options uh included in
the report for the board to consider
um the first one is to retain the status
quo and continue to monitor performance
at the intersection
or
we've sort of three options in the
report the tree that we put in front of
the board the third option
is to install a node right to the
control sign
at the intersection to encourage
drivers to to ignite
um option two
which would include some
more substantial measures such as
installing islands we're not uh
recommending at this stage
i'm happy to take any questions right
questions
because
can we move the mic down a little bit so
you're talking to a person please
um
johnny this the theory is immense
to be frank with traffic coming from
climbing street and then traffic turning
right to the main traffic tuning
from
um
it gets incredibly messy and hold up
um do you think putting the traffic
items the way that it's demonstrated 119
would help or make it
i would say that would make it worse at
the moment which is why we haven't
recommended that option
so what we're recommending at this stage
is
that that option has not
progressed any further there is the
option one which is to retain the status
quo or option three nearly to install
the signage
um would be done first
and then we can continue to monitor and
if we felt like in the future that was
required we could come back to the board
it would need to be added into a future
program
paul
oh well i just look for
monique i'll come back to you
i can't have there any accidents there
i'm just curious do you know there's any
excellent cars tuning right onto high
street from cones road
from
yes
not all of this being driven from an
accident perspective my understanding
was more to do with the delays it was
causing for vehicles coming out of the
albert street
so no i'm not aware of
[Applause]
there's not a lot of people turn right
there to the start
but some of the people did when they
actually stood there to turn right
john england commandments here and
sometimes the endless has to come out of
there and turn a lift
they can't turn the
light on and suddenly you're waiting for
the ambulance and
the animals can't get through
um
it also affects
because it's such a short distance from
the set of lives
sometimes the people wanting to turn
right here
um are sitting there and they miss that
of traffic down civilization burger
avenue which tends to pick up all the
people down alpha street um
quite regular and
they get cheesed off
so that's
well
it's very important i don't support
putting the items in there at all and
it's just trying to educate and it's
been worth these days having people
actually feeling right
and
it's just common sense
interestingly enough i raised this at a
board meeting three or four months ago
that was a corner for an accident
waiting to happen
and i raised that meeting because i'd
come out of a meeting at the
at the hall there
and peop people backing out there
they're in a hurry they see the lights
all right the other way so then they see
some cars coming and they just think
i'll beat that car and if anyone was
coming the other way
it was just always to me a dangerous
situation so i certainly
support this i think from a road safety
and also i think the monitoring is a
good idea
other speakers
kirsten
yeah i certainly support this but
obviously once you've got something that
has done sometimes have an effect on
other things so i guess the only concern
i have is for those people who pull out
of the war memorial champions it's going
to be very difficult for them to turn
around and go back the other direction
they'll have to turn left and then
they'll probably end up using cones
through it as a rep run so there could
be some consequences from this but as
you see the numbers are very slow
i think it's smooth to go and i
certainly think that anyone else
past the war memorial can certainly go
the other way and and i do agree with
the blocking of the rope in the
ambulance i think that's quite a
critical thing that that road needs to
be free it's already very busy and it's
not going to get me quieter with the
break that we've seen
other speakers
there's nothing to reply to paul
so i'll put all those in favor please
reply
i'm just going to mention that jones
extra ends is go too lightly anyway and
goes through that
uh string of the cities in terms of left
there so
it doesn't affect the end of the side
because
i've gotten too light off of elephant
because street
comes with another stick of lights
thank you i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please
contrary
item 6.3 pages 141 45 cold stream tennis
club
andy welcome
[Applause]
hello everybody
the purpose of our report today is to
bring to you
approval to place a
temporary accommodation for cult team
tennis club on the existing building
platform at the newly constructed 10
tennis courts
on cold stream road
contemporary this is largely for to give
cold stream tennis club time to
get their building correctly designed
consented and constructed constructed
the proposal is for this temporary
accommodation to be in position for no
longer than one year
it's expected to have no financial
impact on capital budgets and
is not going to impact the wider
community
as a background to this the culture
returns club have been
have had their current design estimated
and
currently it is exceeding their initial
budgets that they have
they have revised their design and they
are now getting that reprice but the
result of that is a slight delay in
terms of getting their clubhouse up and
running
the intention for the temporary
clubhouse is
not a temporary cough house it is deemed
as a storage facility to allow them to
commence
to get their operations up and running
which they would like to do in
this tennis club season
is the staff recommendation that this
should not really impact
the community in a great way is possibly
a benefit to them in terms of their
allowing their junior clubs to get going
and start working on them they're
currently using the
old brand euro tennis court club at the
moment um and
it is quite small now that we've had an
amalgamation of two clubs
i'll thank you for the report of reds
but i will take questions it's quite a
straightforward
decision
because we
as soon as you put a container on a
building platform we obviously have
legislation that requires building code
and if we apply any
any services to that then obviously they
have to run through a consent process so
by not putting services and it being a
storage facility and a welfare space
they uh we can keep it to a minimum
they're not constrained by consent but
also we can constrain this timeline
i just know you'll see it's got um
three big double ground sliders
um
it is what it is is um they have uh
there was uh paul could you turn it off
please
staff have received a letter um daniel
smith industries have donated this
container so it was a previous container
for something else during the
during the quakes as a temporary
container
um he has offered to give it to them for
for the period of time they need it so
it does look very permanent
but it is
our recommendation to
restrict them to a year um by adding it
potentially to the heads of terms it's a
bit of a sledgehammer to crack it up but
it
will it will maintain that um it is sort
of our concern that we don't want it to
become a
temp to perm solution so
by doing that we can probably restrict
it and we can monitor it to make sure
that it does occur
yeah the questions john
um
very nice that daniel smith estimated
this and i do understand excuse me could
you turn yourself please i do understand
that they have about eight hundred
thirty thousand dollars in kitty so um
they're just readjusting their uh
billing um to fit their budget and um
[Applause]
a
theft and all that drama you know air
for no burger alarm systems and all that
type of garment where a completely
enclosed container
might be long and secure
[Applause]
um
just the security of
where the situation being the vandalism
[Applause]
you're right in terms of the security of
the container but then on the flip side
of it we were concerned with having
constructed a
very nice architecturally designed
building just across the way to then
start to progress and put a just a
straightforward container on there was a
little bit
we were caught between a rock and a half
based on that and that was the decision
that we thought was probably the best
and we are put on the flip side we've
asked them to redecorate it so it
doesn't have lots of sign writing about
eggs and things on the side of it and
we've asked them to put some extra
planting around it just so we can try
and soften its appearance because
there's generally not a taste to put
containers back in from from days gone
by
so that was largely us driven driving
that to make it sort of a bit more
aesthetically pleasing um but
as joan mentioned i've had some feedback
from the club um in the last few days
that they've now engaged an architect to
do their concept designs so they're back
on it so there is a more of a drive to
actually get this clubhouse up and going
and running so
i'm quite confident that this is
actually only ever going to be a
temporary solution for
them right anybody else
i don't think you've got anything to
reply for jen
[Applause]
so i'll put that all those plain teeth
down
[Applause]
thank you
item 6.4 pages 146 to 149
meeting schedule
okay
just before k starts you can now take
your masks off if you'd like to
that was dropping a
life
good evening everyone um
this is a
report that you get most end of years
just setting your
meeting schedule for the following year
we've kept the same
time and place and
date
and i would be very surprised if
somebody changed anything at this point
but
i'm open to you dropping
dropping the time to six
if you like but other than that okay the
report is ready i think we don't like
any questions
someone prepared to move jason moves
andy seconds you should speak to
i think he speaks for himself
anyone else i put all those in favor
please say the content being carried
item
7.1 there's procedure just to receive
that
report from our submissions
i'll move its adoption second for that
duncan put that all those favorite
pieces say hi
i'll move the cheers report duncan
seconds up
i'll put that all those favorite pieces
[Applause]
through two nine point seven
and then you note that public excluded
part nine point eight
and there's a recommendation there
someone prepared to move that
move by paul
seconded by
duncan
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye country
members information exchange where will
we start anything
um of course three holders has
been consuming us
but um
i can't report these things out of the
way um but jim you might
say what we can say and what we can say
you can say anything that wasn't dealt
with in committee
and we won't know if it was
well what i probably should say is that
we're underway
um this week people know more next week
with the procedures that were underway
to apply to the street all those reform
with the government so
we're one of the leading councils we're
leading the way we're very determined
that this
reform is unjust it's undemocratic
undemocratic
and we it's the survival migrants the
survival of our district and our council
in our ability to give great service to
our community like we do now
is is really threatened and i feel
personally that
this reform um
makes me very worried and very scared
like i've never been before about the
future of our district
so but there'll be more to be heard
later so but anyway local government
conference um paul and i did did you go
for it yes you did
no you didn't
i did
conference
um 5-6 meeting in christchurch i
attended
with
some councillors
it was
yes we had um
new zealand there we had
in
dia there we all listen silently
and too scared to say anything but none
of us really agreed with what they were
trying to tell us but
um so that was
interesting i guess but um
not very rewarding as far as i was
concerned but
um something that we need to go um
through bring your air through advisory
um meetings we've had those we're
getting on
with new leases at the airfield so we're
trying to make that happen
we have had special meetings on three
waters
a meeting
with some of our councillors last friday
with two labour mps amber sweden
sarah palette trying to tell them
our concerns and voicing our concerns
and letting them know where we were at
where we come from
um
it was
they listened
but yes
anyway you have to try don't you
um
and then we've been having council
management workshops with senior
managers the last couple of weeks i'm
looking to
forward for the next year so it's been
um
it's very busy um
a long day some days on tuesdays um but
anyway it's been
i
that think
lord
say thank you to the councillors for the
work they're doing on three waters i
think this council has been absolutely
magnificent from what i have observed
today
and just a couple of little things i
could add there was a delegation
you might find it interesting the
delegation sent down from wellington to
have a look at rural schemes i gave the
article to the mayor so you probably
know this uh there were five women that
came down
to look at the rural schemes and get it
and they went to otago
uh and you all know rural schemes as
circulated the water gets on the scheme
to the highest point and then comes down
by gravity feed usually from the tank
continue they went up this points on the
sky steep property and they had all the
schemes
explained to them and then the leader
from wellington the lady said how do you
get the tanker up a steep track
that's how much knowledge that they've
got absolutely unbelievable no so just
this is what you guys are dealing with
jason
um nothing too crazy this month uh just
too many things to report on so we get a
meeting with community center there was
ongoing issues with vandalism so they're
currently looking at hopefully getting
some cameras in school maybe
and they're
hopefully going to be getting their
flaws done in their main
area done very soon
and the five a day is preparing for us
150th and four years time
thank you
i've attended this um southport trailer
safety traffic project working here on
your behalf
um
your board briefing on the 27th and um
last week we had submissions to the
district
thank you thank you duncan
murray
um well duncan was there with me i went
to the seattle gaming committee's
meeting i wanted to have on that it's
going to survive up to three waters too
and i went up to charles upper village
and met with a lot of the residents so
there's more opinions about parking and
hot dinners up there
i think the real problem is that village
is being built without enough room for
staff to park off the road that's the
real problem
um
the residents of ashley is somewhat
concerned over speeding in the village
because a lot of
you younger people moved in there
and those roads over here some some of
you will be well aware there's no
footpaths
so the children play on the road the
people walk up and down the road
everybody walks up and down the road
suddenly to be confronted by a car doing
a hundred plus k's
is a bit of a problem it seems to be
um aggravated by the fact that the
railways have done up the rail crossing
they spent a couple of weeks doing that
i put new sleepers at utah steel i went
to the onboard briefing and the other
thing i've noticed is a lot of mention
about parking i've seen going backwards
and forwards one of the problems seems
to be that on saturday we get a lot of
cars excuse me murray could you turn you
off my console sorry this is meant to be
streaming so everyone can hear your
wisdom yeah there seems to be a problem
with people bringing empty trailers into
the town
and taking up some of the parking spaces
i noticed that one side's in the main
street there was a team trailer and a
car taking out two and a half spaces and
had nothing on the trailer at all
i've done a bit of research on i've
found out a lot of people are bringing
their rubbish to the rubbish stuff and
then doing their shopping on the way
home
i don't know how we get around this but
maybe it's worth sort of
an article about it
and
um
yeah the other problem was that there's
a
bit of a problem with
a track that runs through green street
from south brook road to all the
residential houses above it and it's
grass it's never been
turned into an all-weather track and
several of the people who lived down
there have been on to me about the fact
that it's not really satisfactory in
winter
so i actually went to the trouble of
walking through it myself and it goes a
hell of a long way that trend and it
goes off in several different directions
so i'm wondering if perhaps it's
something that we should look at
because we have done single parts in
other areas but that one's all grass
can you give the exact areas to k at the
end of the meeting so
some staff can have a look at that
yeah i haven't mentioned it before but
uh and the other problem i had is that
the data's complaining about spanning
the south about not because i lived
there either but one of them down the
road had an up and down of the
contractor where he nearly had an
accident and the problem is that the
contractor
came up with this wonderful story that
because it was rural on one side he
could do anything he liked him
she's going to put some 50k signs up
there trying to slow them down
so that's all i've done thanks married
christian
jones covered three waters so the only
other big piece of legislation that is
like a um murray okay
it was like
out of nowhere was the intensification
of housing
um we have no warning of that and that
will have some direct implications on
our district plan and how we deal with
that in the near future um
if we look at some of the central
government
legislation
that they're expecting to put through in
the next year or two it's incredibly
busy and so we actually have no idea
whether the time frame is going to be
able to be met
so that
means at the moment we have to treat it
like it's just the bill
it's not law and basically continue with
business as usual
with um hoping that
um
we can get our district plan through and
through the process
without then having to change an entire
chunk
of our resident children's city chapters
and everything that's related to that
because of this
new proposal so though for any of those
of you who haven't heard about it that's
talking about
um less controlled women controls in the
medium
town centre
um residential areas which used to be
areas one
and which means they can go up to three
stories high they have up to 50 flight
coverage and there's a lot less
restriction on um
how much impact that has on their
neighbours and there is no resource
consent process that comes with that so
that is quite significant particularly
for provincial towns who aren't used to
intensification of that nature
so that's another little piece of joy
that's been spread amongst this to work
on going forward
as well as
the rna changes and the changes to the
people's
[Music]
and it's quite a good experience i think
so some of the staff who work on the
footpaths etc and to just improve their
awareness of how
you know footpath
um
away with etc and
walkways onto the roads how important it
is to
make them as accessible as possible for
people so it was a good little meeting
it would be
um
have you been given
any indication regarding obviously the
high technology type housing project
um is that liable to be in zions or if
you live in this belgian
section next to you would you be afraid
no it's
it's only in what is called the median
density which what we've known is reds
one whereas esther was
risk two so it's predominantly affecting
that central part of each town
in the medium
and so
it's
more it's designed for the cities to be
frank and it's really not designed for
chill towns but and it will override all
of our design controls that we have for
building um except there is some skills
on setback the staff are going through
the detail now to try and work out which
rules are going to have to change if
that becomes more um but at the moment
as we've said with because there's not
enough detail we really have to just
keep going business as usual with our
operative plan and keep progressing
the submissions from them
i think there might be an intention for
once
the staff have worked out exactly all
the implications that they'll come and
bring
specifically about what those changes
are because it will have quite a
significant impact as fast
thank you okay morris
i just attended
three meetings of central district
training meeting um
district land meeting in the awards
group
thank you
paul
yes um just to follow from what the
chairman was saying about the amount of
knowledge some of our
local
government ministers know about three
waters i actually attended a meeting
with minister mahuta and oxford for one
of oxford's small wells
and while she was looking around well
this feeds the whole of waimakariri
and she actually seriously thought the
sweet tiny well has been the whole of
waimakariri so let's just
see how out of touch they are with the
um the water snows and their own
properties
but um anyway um
three waters is happening and it's a
real worry we've been working a lot of
time
i think there's a scarier thing coming
and it's local government reforms
and i think the pre-war is just the
start of um possibly the end of some
councils around
new zealand as it's looking so most of
them even most of them um
the whisper out there they want
14 councils out of
the total of 68 or something 67 67 at
the moment
and that's a real real worry um
as they take some of the the big juice
the localism out of council so
i think it's a real very
just add on to what kirsten was saying
about the um
local
rmas and
whatever i think one of the worst things
they are is they've taken away the needs
for any car parks if you build a house
or
one of those three-story buildings here
you don't need to have a car park
whatsoever on your property
so um where's people going to go to
parks
it's going to call back onto councils
they're not even going to have any car
parks whatsoever on any property so um
that's a wee bit of a worry
um
as concern as everybody knows of funding
for roading the land transport cut
it's basically six million dollars out
of their um budgets and um it's a real
worry um what we're going to do in the
future because we just seem to be um
spending their moneys on other things
that's
to me doesn't make sense and taking away
from the maintenance and they have the
hard core
business what council need to do and are
expected to do
and that's worse than we're expected to
do and
we
our council passes the budget
goes to lead transport
and um while we've got the money for the
site for it they're 50 percent 51
percent
normally paid
they just take a big extra repair and
say we haven't got the money to do it
and yet
everybody knows what they spend money on
i suspect a lot they're being told to
redirect that to the new rail line to
the auckland airport it might have been
their fault
possibly too well um
being involved with the airport we've
got some safety concerns there with um
gates being left open and cars driving
on the airfield and so that's
pretty
important thing to get sorted out in
that area
but
the biggest thing i want to bring out to
you on the 28th of november
at 115 our local cadet units
have got a parade
um in front of the building here so and
they're going to change the name to
number 88 granular squadron year
training course the next
long of the young people around the
district
um
[Applause]
and
no yeah
[Music]
there's ear training core yes
they're doing a wonderful wonderful job
after some of their young
children around the area and um i've
been blown away by some of the uh
the atmosphere of the place when you go
there and the um the quality of the
the kids though um producing there so
i've
thoroughly endorsed everybody in this
room um to go to that um
let's see
28th of november yeah
you know i just think it's going to be
such a good thing we need to
go there and support them in every way
they can so it's a it's a really really
big thing for
our district it was training
and no doubt i actually thought joan
would have already got but
we've been so busy with everything else
but that was an important thing to bring
up i thought
thank you moving on item 11
is for your information
item 12 is booked and 12.1 12.2
for your information i can't help but
think
maybe if you were agreeable i could talk
to the green green space people we've
had a delegation from bernard and he's
not asking for much
i noted we carried over
1580 in the general landscape budget
last year that would put a nice chair up
there see wouldn't it
i could just ask them to bring a little
report to us and we can consider it then
if you're happy okay
um we are
getting a report on
landscape budgeting in the next month or
two so i'll just tell grant to add that
in just mention that if the board to
have a preliminary law without
committing themselves just seemed
sensible to me
because we do plenty right so there are
no media items and no questions there's
no urgent general business so
that brings us the end of the meeting
itself